une seule caméra pour accompagner la
délégation de washington en visite dans
un camp de migrants mineurs à la
frontière mexicaine annonce ce mercredi
de la porte parole de la maison blanche
une caméra poufre à partie de ce voyage
et veillera à ce qu'une couverture des
images poule soit fourni à toutes les
chaînes afin que vous puissiez tous vous
rendre compte par vous-même et proposer
une analyse de ces images ces images
parfois floue tourné à carrizo springs
au texas sont les seuls refusé diffusée
par toutes les chaînes de télévision
américaines un traitement médiatique
très confidentielle justifiée par la
crise sanitaire selon washington
mais qui déclenche une vague
d'indignation dans une tribune publiée
dans le washington post le photographe
de presse john moore auteur d'un ouvrage
sur la frontière entre les etats-unis et
le mexique dénonce un manque de
transparence faisant même un
rapprochement entre joe biden et son
prédécesseur donald trump
nous sommes passés de la politique de
tolérance zéro de l'air trump envers les
immigrants à une politique d'accès 0 de
leur bail donne pour les journalistes
couvrant l'immigration cette évolution
est sans précédent dans l'histoire
moderne
même critique de ce célèbre sénateur
républicain au texas administration
donne à imposer une obligation de
silence une interdiction aux médias
devenir pendant quatre ans nous avons
entendu les démocrates parler sans cesse
d'enfants en cage et bien joe biden ne
veut absolument pas qu'il vous voyez les
cages de baden sa solution est de dire
pas de caméra pas d' équipe de
télévision pas de médias pendant sa
campagne présidentielle joe biden avait
promis de mener une politique migratoire
plus humaine et plus transparente
ce mercredi le président américain a
remis ce dossier entre les mains de la
vice-présidente kamala harris une tâche
difficile at il concédé
tenu pour le moment à l'écart des
journalistes